geht die mutter aller wissenschaften
2500 jahre nach ihrer entstehung waren
sind sokrates platon und aristoteles nur
noch geistiges treibgut belächelt und
verschmäht von den erfolgreichen kräften
der postmodernen gesellschaft den
ingenieuren juristen und betriebswirte
lohnt es sich dennoch philosophie zu
studieren und kann man damit überhaupt
geld verdienen
angeln ist die einzige art von
philosophie von der man satt werden kann
ich bin froh weil ich in meinem studium
zurecht kommen also ich freue mich das
nicht irgendwie noch platten und so
greift ist was weiß ich noch nicht
wenn man ein hobby braucht ist es schon
eine gute möglichkeit das zu studieren
ich habe genug andere hobbys haben
philosophie studium vielleicht die
philosophiestudentin ich mag lieber ein
studienfach als hobby als dass ich mein
hobby zum beruf macht dafür was braucht
man diese studiengänge nix mit dem man
sonderlich viel arbeit oder dienst für
die gesellschaft leisten kann sind
philosophen wirklich nutzlos für die
gesellschaft
wir fragen nach bei zwei promovierten
philosophen
den menschen auf nutzen hin zu
orientieren ist ja von der verzweigung
es ist eigentlich eine unverschämtheit
die kinder darauf auf diese weise zu
stellen die haben ein freies leben
verdient wie alle anderen auch und weil
wir das so brauchen erzählen wir sehen
diese richtung das geht noch nicht gar
nicht in den augen der öffentlichkeit
bin ich wahrscheinlich der klischee
philosoph aber es bleibt gar nichts
anderes übrig als der zu sein wenn man
problem auf den grund kommen will
christian wannenmacher jahrgang 1961
studium der philosophie an der lmu
münchen studienbeginn 1982 promotion
2011 finanziell ermöglicht durch ein
erbe die philosophie kommt von der
politik beratung im alten griechenland
das heißt es ist ein elite studium für
gut geratene bürgersöhne oder eben auch
solche die sich in der politik behaupten
sollten
du brauchst die zeit dafür nachzudenken
und auch die ergebnisse abwarten zu
können denn das nachdenken vollzieht
sich in fleisch und blut
mit anderen worten du warst zeit dinge
zu verarbeiten
bist du so weit bist wer aber nicht
ererbt
musste er später taxen fahren oder hartz
4 beziehen inzwischen wagen sich in
deutschland noch 20.000 studierende an
das scheinbar antiquierte irgendwie aus
der zeit gefallene fach
im vergleich dazu bwl studieren knapp
210.000 dem start ist das nur recht
an vielen hochschulen begrenzt er den
zugang für das fach philosophie die
philosophen verdammen den reichtum nur
weil wir ihn schlecht gebrauchen also
ich werde sicherlich taxifahrerin werden
ich glaube dass philosophie heute in der
unübersichtlichen welt mehr platz hat
alles als jemals zuvor und auch
stellenwert haben solche diese
deutungshoheit der philosophie gerät
immer mehr in vergessenheit und in wird
immer unwichtiger früher waren die ja
auch nicht nur philosophen sondern haben
ja noch viele andere dinge nebenher
gemacht und ja also ich teilweise auch
noch mit technik beschäftigt und heute
teilt das viel mehr auf die
verschiedenen gruppen auf so dass man
viel viel spezialisierter ist was machst
du mit deinem studium was machst du der
philosophie den leuten die mich das
fragen kann ich nur antworten was sie
eigentlich ohne diese schulden ihren
leben machen
monika gatte jahrgang 1967 studium an
der hochschule für philosophie münchen
studien dauert zehn jahre promotion 2009
lehrbeauftragte für philosophie an der
universität der bundeswehr münchen
dimitri ist einer von monika götz
studenten eigentlich büffelt er luft und
raumfahrttechnik belegt aber freiwillig
auch philosophie seminare
heute geht es um die grenzen des
bewusstseins freiheit sind nicht das was
unser nachdenken was uns befruchtet oder
auch weiter treibt dieses philosophische
forschen ist ja angst dass uns streben
lässt staunen lässt vor dem dann noch
die augen auf aber sehe ich denn da
alles und in der wahrnehmung eigentlich
berührt sich alles nur unser bewusstsein
ist er in der lage zu differenzieren ich
sehen sehen ich sehe ich sie den tisch
ich sehe die wand aber zunächst das
phänomen wahrnehmung eines das wo sich
alles berühren und das bewusstsein oder
der verstand setzt die frage ist in der
lage das zu differenzieren also dass
zuzuordnen dem denken zu sagen hat das
sind jetzt einzelne identitäten
sozusagen man ist ja wirklich tief rein
gegangen die materie man hat viel
nachgedacht es war wirklich auch erstmal
schwierig für mich da gedankengänge so
vielfältig und tiefe zu fassen
und ja also mich hat das halt auch
bereich hat ich habe lange von dem von
dem seminar sag ich mal geschöpft als
techniker muss man nicht nur wissen wie
man technischen sachen entwickelt und
wie man einen die technischen probleme
herangeht sondern muss auch wissen wofür
man das ganze macht und hilflos ist ein
guter einstieg dafür auch die sachen aus
moralischer sicht des philosophen für
sich zu betrachten eine gute lehrende
bin ich dann wenn die studierenden ihren
eigenen weg gehen wenn sie nicht in
meine fußstapfen nachlaufen ich bin auch
meinen eigenen ich habe noch finden
müssen weil ich ganz einfach aber
durchgehalten habe ich dann würde ich
sagen bin ich gut wenn ich im seminar
etwas möglich machen konnte etwas zur
sprache bringen konnte das flex draußen
geblieben wäre
die philosophie rudert nicht einmal um
einen besser
in zeiten des marketings wo nur der
schöne schein zählt bleibt sie sich
stoisch treu im ringen um erkenntnis und
selbst die stellen ihre vertreter in
frage ein understatement das verwirrt
und leicht abgewertet werden kann nur
mit logischen fähigkeiten probleme
aufzuschlüsseln ist wahrscheinlich nicht
das ziel das man an steuern darf man
muss auch frustrationstoleranz haben und
auch reflexion barrieren akzeptieren
können und dann lange mit ihnen kämpfen
ohne geduld für dicke bretter ist ein
philosophiestudium nicht zu ende zu
führen
für mehr als die hälfte der philosophie
studenten sind die bretter so dick dass
sie das studium nicht in der
regelstudienzeit schaffen
sie überziehen im schnitt zwei semester
und kommen mit einem durchschnittlichen
alter von 27 jahren auf den arbeitsmarkt
[Musik]
die philosophen haben die welt nur
verschieden interpretiert
es kommt aber darauf an sie zu verändern
die sache ist die dass irgendwann
philosophie studiert glaube ich man
schon in dem moment so befriedigt ist
mit dem was man in dem moment macht dass
man auch das ist momentan noch völlig
fern liegt sich darüber gedanken zu
machen ganz pragmatisch wo wir später
landen
das ja auch denke in deutschland ein
problem als ich also freunde von mir die
auch an dem ausland philosophie
studieren die bekommen auch jobs bei
irgendwelchen großen
wirtschaftsunternehmen und verdienen
auch gut geld bei der anderen berufe
führen dazu dass ich weniger zeit hat
für mich weniger zeit für meine gedanken
weniger zeit auch für
zwischenmenschlichkeit und dadurch
entstehen ja erst gerade die probleme
dafür dass jeder philosophie studieren
sollte bevor er so war es auch mal
früher
[Musik]
früher da waren sie geachtet und verehrt
man hörte auf philosophen und auf das
was sie zu sagen hatten
über die gesellschaft und ihre probleme
längst vergangene tage
nicht so aufs geld gucken ist das ist
man wird sich als mensch nicht gerecht
es reicht doch epikur meinte mal wenn
genug zu wenig ist ihm ist nichts gut
man muss nicht von wasser und brot leben
das wir nicht damit nicht sagen aber
inneres glück eine innere zufriedenheit
innere freiheit im laufe seines 70 oder
80 jährigen lebens kam zu erfahren
das ist doch unbezahlbar ich würde
jemanden philosophie zu studieren
empfehlen der wirklich ein anliegen hat
und sich sicher ist dass ihnen das
weiter trägt also man muss fragen
mitbringen und sich nicht erst die
fragen geben lassen
es braucht heute mut für ein
philosophiestudium
wer ihn hat wagt ein leben gegen den
zeitgeist kann persönlich viel gewinnen
und geht voraus auf einem weg an dessen
ende das seien wieder mehr bedeutet als
dass haben
[Musik]